welcome to Walt Disney World the most
magical place on Earth and every kid's
Paradise
okay maybe not let's discuss why Disney
World and all the Disney theme parks
were not made for children now you might
be thinking wait isn't Disney the
happiest place on Earth isn't it
specifically designed for kids to have
fun and make magical memories well not
really while it's true that Disney World
and the other Disney theme parks are
certainly family friendly and geared
towards providing entertainment and
enjoyment for all ages the truth is that
they weren't initially designed with
kids in mind the idea for Disneyland
came from Walt Disney himself who wanted
to create a place where adults could
experience the same sense of wonder and
joy that children do he thought of the
park as his own personal playground from
the beginning he made it as a place
where adults would want to go and
perhaps bring their kids along now
though it's important to understand that
Disney is a massive multi-billion dollar
Corporation and like any Corporation its
primary goal is to make money obviously
there are many different ways that
Disney World can generate Revenue but
one of the biggest is through ticket
sales and who buys tickets to Disney
World adults in fact many adults even
visit the park with without children or
with children who are too young to
remember the trip myself included these
adult guests can bring in just as much
revenue as kids can and Disney knows it
also let's consider the price Disney
World tickets are not cheap and they
only seem to be getting more and more
expensive if you're a parent trying to
bring your family to Disney World you're
probably gonna have to save up for a
while before you can afford it this
means that Disney World is more geared
towards those with the financial means
to afford it rather than larger families
with children who might not have the
disposable income to pay for such an
expensive vacation now before you start
thinking I'm crazy hear me out Disney is
known for its magical child-friendly
atmosphere but if you take a closer look
you'll see that there are actually quite
a few things about Disney World that are
not necessarily geared towards kids
there are a lot of adult oriented
attractions and experiences at Disney
world that kids might not be interested
in for example there are numerous fine
dining restaurants wine tastings and
nightlife options at the resort that are
more geared towards adults there are
also adult themed areas like the Disney
Springs shopping district that kids
might not find very exciting one of the
biggest draws to Disney World though is
Epcot and especially how you can drink
around the world at Epcot
and park has a series of pavilions made
to look like and sponsored by other
countries such as Germany Italy Mexico
and Canada and each of these Pavilions
you can drink the country's alcoholic
beverage of choice and move on to the
next one thus allowing you to drink
around the world another reason that
Disney World might not be entirely for
kids is that it's simply too big and too
complex for them to fully appreciate the
Disney World Resort spans over 40 square
miles or twice the size of Manhattan and
it includes four separate theme parks
two water parks and dozens of hotels
restaurants and other attractions that's
a lot of ground to cover and it can be
overwhelming for kids and even adults to
try to see and do everything also if you
like what you're seeing hit that
subscribe button for more videos like
this at Disney World the theme park
experience itself can be overwhelming
for young children too with long lines
crowds and the need to stay with a
parent or Guardian at all times this can
make it difficult for kids to fully
enjoy the experience making it more
suitable for adults one thing that
always stands out to me at Disney World
though is the immersion in every Park
every land every ride the one thing that
never fails to amaze me is how well they
immerse you into the environment take
Star Wars Galaxy's Edge for example you
feel like you're really in the Star Wars
Galaxy building lightsabers and piloting
the Millennium Falcon or take Pandora
the world of Avatar it really feels like
you're in James Cameron's World riding a
Banshee or gazing at the Pandora and
floating mountains this type of
immersion is something kids definitely
wouldn't be able to pick up on no this
was brought to the Disney parks
specifically for adults to appreciate
additionally some other rides and
attractions at Disney World are simply
not suitable for young children for
example the Tower of Terror and Space
Mountain are both thrilling rides that
may be too intense for younger kids
speaking of younger kids it really kind
of sucks in some ways to go to Disney
World with them don't get me wrong I
loved seeing my son waddle up to Mickey
Mouse and hold his hand and in seeing
the smile on his face while he watched
the nighttime fireworks but the days are
long and hard whenever you bring a child
you have to account for potty breaks in
nap time going home early not being able
to ride the big rides pushing a stroller
and so much more as an adult you don't
have to worry about any of those things
without kids along for the ride you can
go at your own pace see what you want to
see ride what you want to ride drink
what you want to drink I've been on
trips both with and without kids and let
me tell you the trips without kids are
much more relaxing so while Disney World
may seem like it's all about the kids on
the outside there are actually a lot of
things at the park that are more geared
towards adults that being said there is
still plenty of child-friendly
attractions and experiences at Disney
World and kids can certainly have a
great time at the park but it's
important to remember that Disney World
was not solely made for children and
there are many aspects of the park that
are geared towards a more adult audience
ultimately it's up to each individual
guest to decide what they want to
experience while they're there and
whether they think Disney World is for
kids or for adults
foreign
[Music]